Nao who saw the reality of our acoustics It's a
real situation for us.
It's impossible to convert all of them
into data.How about we lend you the sound department's one basement floor and two floors above ground?
We guarantee free activities and continuation.
The
sound department's fee is secured by duplicating the sound source data, selling it, and leasing it, and we
receive a fee.
No
, I understand, so the contract is concluded, so if you get the tweet effect, please leave the
country during the air raids and move out
.  I can't help it
, so please do it by the end of this month.
The system is yes Yes, I want to face this way Butter